this is Startalk
I'm your host Neil deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist and I'm here
with my coach Chuck nice Joe hey hey hey
hey Neil what's happening okay of course
we're in the corona verse yeah so I can
only touch Chuck through my audio and
electronic vibes heck that's not true me
oh you always touch my heart okay so
today we're talking about the corona
virus as it relates to climate change
but you hadn't thought about that one
him actually I have no excuse me well
except I ain't asking you about it oh
this is true I need some bike some
expert commentary then you could joke
about it okay that's how you roll sounds
good alright so it turns out right up
the street from us is the Goddard
Institute for Space Studies and is a
branch of NASA that specializes in like
climate and atmospheres of planets and
many people don't know about it it's up
near Columbia in fact it's part of the
Columbia campus and it's on the same
block that has that corner restaurant
where the it just says restaurant oh
yeah from Seinfeld from Seinfeld write
this on that block it's on that block
yeah it's very men in black you know
it's like it's such a nondescript facade
you have no like you would have no idea
that this is a part of NASA we are not
authorized to comment on that fact
further okay so what I've got here is I
don't like home maybe I could calm chief
climate scientist what we know he's
director of NASA's Goddard Institute for
Space Studies in New York Gavin Schmidt
Gavin welcome to Startalk I know Chuck
last three all right all right I think
you've been on before so let me just say
it let me welcome you back thanks and
today we want to talk about the impact
of the corona virus on climate and maybe
more interestingly
vice-versa all right how has climate
change influenced how and why the corona
virus can spread so before we get there
just what can you tell us in general
about co2 emissions because that's you
know the big driver in our atmosphere
for how much heat we retain heat energy
we retain so how does that why should
anyone think about the corona virus and
co2 in the same sentence oh yeah and
they're broadening out a little bit one
of the things that we do as part of our
economy and part of the energy that we
generate and the electricity that we use
is that we burn fossil fuels when we
burn those fossil fuels coal oil natural
gas it produces carbon dioxide that
comes outside goes into the atmosphere
where it turns out to be a really really
important greenhouse gas and that's
causing the planet to walk right so the
the accumulated amount of carbon
emissions that we've had you know since
the Industrial Revolution you know 150
years ago has warmed the planet by about
two degrees Fahrenheit over that time
period and the and the warming that
we're seeing now you know decade by
decade by decade is is almost so
entirely due to our activities but it's
not just come down outside it's it's
also the pollutants that we're putting
into the air that you can touch and see
and feel soot smog all of these things
impact the climate but just just to be
clear if co2 had like was purple and we
would we would be much more plugged in
to its role as pollutant in the
atmosphere well yeah so we've we've
increased the amount of carbon dioxide
in the atmosphere by about 40 percent
over over that period so so that's
really quite a substantial amount and
and we can see we can see the other
pollutants right and right now if you're
in a city where there's a lockdown are
you're actually not seeing them your air
has been cleaner now this month than
perhaps it has been in many many
decades and that's true in in China it's
true in northern Italy it's true on the
the East Coast it's true in in parts of
California because because we're we've
stopped driving around so much so the
the amount of transportation that's
going on the amount of internal
combustion engines that are being turned
on is gone way way down and those are
producers of things like nitrous oxides
NO x no.2 which are a component of smog
that leads to high ozone levels which
are very unhealthy but just a quick a
quick question there is no element with
the letter X so NO x yeah you're
referring to what so a no X I is is a
whole range of nitrous oxides that are n
o2 and o4 no.6 complex you slew n2o5
okay so that's the analogy break
variable X telling you how many oxygen
atoms are attached to your nitrogen atom
facts exactly gotcha
so so there's one class of oxygen itrex
oxides that are very reactive and are
both ozone precursors and unhealthy in
and of themselves and we have in because
they come out of internal combustion
those have been going way way down early
um Gavin this problem is solved I mean I
don't even know why we're having this
show it sounds to me like we're all good
yeah well see okay so this is this is a
thing you know we know that these
pollutants and we know that comes
outside comes from our industrial and
agricultural activities right so we've
known this for centuries I if the answer
was as simple as let's just stop doing
everything that we're doing you're right
we would have solved this problem and
right now we're doing half of that right
we're we're we're half stopping a lot of
the things that are producing some of
this these pollutants but I don't know
how much fun you're having right now but
I
know that this is really a final and
covenant solution but just ask
tell me about air travel as well is that
that's a contributor at just as driving
is right
um so air travel is about three percent
of global carbon emissions and obviously
air travel has gone way way down in the
last couple of months but it gives you a
sense of how difficult the carbon
dioxide problem is it's because even if
we stop flying
that's only 3% we stop driving that's
maybe another five ten percent because
we haven't stopped the trucks we haven't
stopped the trains we haven't stopped
the shipping and so the total emissions
in cut for carbon dioxide that we're
expecting to change as a function of
this as a function of the coronavirus is
perhaps only about five to ten percent
of global emissions puts the please not
that much plus the farming footprint
hasn't changed for carbon dioxide
correct right and electricity you know
we're still generating electricity using
our internet not all of which is carbon
footprint it but a great deal of it it
globally is though particularly coal
right I mean you still have a bunch of
countries that are burning coal and
recently in America you know we we had
to bring it back and so you know we we
haven't we haven't brought coal is
having its lunch eaten for it in the
marketplace and so coal in the u.s. and
in most of Western Europe and Japan is
is is on its is on its last legs but
there are still a lot of coal-fired
power stations being built being used in
China India parts of Eastern Europe and
the like so nothing you're a medical
expert but let me just see what you know
of this if the air quality is a little
better is it too early to know whether
the cleaner air is actually saving the
lives of people who
might have otherwise been on the brink
with respiratory issues so I mean that
that's a that's a great great point we
know the heavy amounts of particulates
you know small particles in the air are
very very deleterious to people's health
I mean and and they kill literally
hundreds of thousands of people
prematurely every year in in China and
similarly in India and in other parts of
the world so reducing those pollutants
is a health gain but whether you know
how many lives we're saving or how many
lives were not cutting short for like a
month of clean air or two months of
clean air that's a little bit trickier
because most of the problems are
associated with persistent exposure and
so if we if we kind of cut it down and
then kept it cut down then I think we'd
be seeing many many thousands of maybe
even hundreds of thousands of lives and
we should be working towards that but
something we're still something we're
still in the early stages of I think
medically of understanding is you're
right a couple of months of clean air
was that relative to years and years
exposure so if you did have this
respiratory susceptibility to pollution
early evidence has been showing that you
are more susceptible to the virus to the
corona virus and its effects on your
lives have you seen that or read about
that
I've only read about it and again you
know I've just seen these kind of you
know kind of pre prints that have been
popping up to suggest that there is an
impact of heavy pollution making your
susceptibility to corona virus or worse
so people at a pre printers OH
so science works much faster than our
ability to publish it and so the
scientists who are working at the
cutting edge of the corona virus both
the the epidemiology and the biology and
the impacts are producing science at a
very very rapid rate and they're just
kind of throwing up their papers on to
what are called pre print servers where
you can look and that everyday there are
hundreds of papers being put
on these servers where you can get a
really cutting-edge view of what people
are doing now the problem with free
prints is that you don't know if it's
right and it hasn't been checked it
hasn't been peer reviewed and so there's
some stuff up there that is obviously
not going to be correct and there's kind
of be more confusing than than useful
like the one that said that the aliens
brought the corona virus that's a
preprint that not not yet peer reviewed
hypothesis yeah that's what they want
you to believe the preprint is kind of
like a a rough-cut screen basically yeah
no no screening
it's a rough cut it's just a rough cut
okay without any screening okay so tell
me about one of the things you and your
entire institution as director of KISS
Goddard Institute for Space Studies
relies on is climate modeling modeling
in general which is quite quite a
daunting task when the models you create
and intended to represent reality have
many many variables in it and you have
to sort of get a handle on all those
variables is there any connectivity
between modeling climate and modeling
the spread of the corona virus and which
modeling works best for you is it
swimwear or evening wear you don't want
to see me I once got caught on on Google
Streetview
running through the park like with my
shirt off and it was there for many many
years as like you know it's a night and
I it was just horrible
sorry I derailed us what Chuck have you
seen there's a comic or something a few
months ago there was a hurricane is
coming through
it was it was a Trump joke it says
something like Trump wasn't interested
in climate change until he heard that
the European models were doing better
than the American that's pretty fun oh
that's really good that's damn funny
yeah sorry sorry but Maura we've
connected coronavirus sorry that was a
question before I took us down a rabbit
hole right so you know let's be clear
models are absolutely fundamental to the
scientific enterprise right you know if
you want to make a prediction for
something that's going to happen to be
able to test your theories you have to
be able to quantify that you quantify
that using a model now there's different
kinds of models and I think a lot of the
conversation related to the coronavirus
in them and the epidemiological models
that are being used is that people don't
really understand why how there are
different kinds of models right so you
know there are some models where you
know you get a bunch of data and
basically you just fit a line through it
or you fit a curve through it and you
say okay well that's what's gonna happen
okay some of the boys just to be clear
the model is intended to be able to not
only predict what will happen in the
future but assess the intensity of what
will happen in the future so but you put
a line through the data that you have
and assume that the continuation of that
line or curve takes you to where you can
now alert authorities right so I mean so
if you're if you're on an exponential
growth path then you know you don't want
to make a linear extrapolation from that
you want to make an exponential is
speculation but that only goes so far
and then what happens when you you
Institute some public policy and then
really that the system has shifted and
so you really need to model that a
little bit differently and so the whole
idea is to be able to make predictions
so that we can be prepared or more
prepared than than we currently appear
to be so there's there's models where
basically you're just fitting a line
there are models that are more
sophisticated where you're actually
trying to track you know how a virus
goes from one person to another person
to another person in what kind of
circumstances and some of that modeling
is
very very complex some of it is you know
you have little agents who are kind of
infecting each other and you're trying
to aggregate that to the the national or
the global numbers that's very very
complicated the fitting a straight line
and stuff is very simple but it turns
out that oftentimes you get a good sense
of where things are going with the
simpler models but if you actually want
to make a useful prediction you need to
do that more complex modeling and with
respect to climates you know there is
the there's the same kind of thing you
know you can look at the temperatures
over time and you can put a straight
line through it anything that that's a
prediction it's not terrible
but it isn't going to tell you what's
going to happen the next time there's a
volcano or the next time there's a
nonlinear event or the next time that we
do something about emissions here's what
you're saying is you can't predict when
you have unpredictable things you can't
predict with precision or accuracy when
you have unpredictable forces jumping in
to mess up your model well it's hard to
know exactly where things are going to
go because the answers from your model
are hopefully gonna impact public policy
and people are going to make different
decisions based on what they think is
going to happen right so then lockdowns
that we've seen those are are in
response to models that said well if you
don't do that
it's gonna go off exponentially and so
they said well we don't want that so
let's change things and now that's a new
element that you know and that's gonna
give a different answer so it's not that
the models changed right but the
scenarios have changed you know okay so
with that in mind because the important
thing if you know and this is just from
I'm not the scientist here I'm listening
to this I want to know what have you
gotten right that I can rely on looking
into the future so can you give us an
example of what models you have already
executed that said hey this is the deal
and we got it right or even more
importantly we were way too conservative
right so going back to my field right
where I know more of more of that kind
of stuff so in climate you know we
started seriously looking at the calmed
outside problem in the 1960s and people
made predictions then that said okay
well by the end of the century you know
we all have wound up by about a degree
Celsius and we did and but it wasn't
just like you know oh it's gonna get
warmer it was it was quite precise and
then they say well Kay but up in the
stratosphere which is the part of the
atmosphere above the weather they said
well actually something weird is going
to happen there it's gonna get colder
and it turns out that that happened as
well and then they said well you know
the water vapor is gonna go up and they
said well you know that happened to and
all of these things that we predicted
the increase of heat in the ocean we
predicted that at the rate that which is
actually warming up so chuck it means
they're bad exactly that's my point so
my point is this what are you guys doing
wrong that nobody gives a [ __ ] that you
got all this stuff right right
that's a social issue that there has to
be solved okay yeah so the issue the
issue is is the one that we see just a
quick thing for the Celsius illiterate
Americans you said the temperature will
go up by one degree Celsius one degree
Celsius if I remember my math equals one
point eight degrees Fahrenheit and
that's how much that's how much we've
warmed so let me just I just want to
bring this segment to a fast close
because we have more of the show on a
continuing the topic with yet another
guest so just to be clear the fact that
there is a virus pandemic is not itself
of interest to you a climate scientist
what's of interest to you is the effect
that that pandemic has had on our
consumption of fossil fuels and how that
then affects your climate modeling well
I'm pretty interested in what's
happening with the virus
just as a basic human being I'm not
purely a good to know your human beings
thank you for but you know very well my
climate scientists had I'm very
interested in how this is impacting air
quality radiation temperatures going
forward carbon dioxide going forward
yeah and we're diving into that in much
the same way after September 11th we had
weeks of no traffic no air traffic and
so I remember reading the astronaut
accounts for that note that no liar
could see the contrails croc Criss
crossing the country in the world over
that period of time see it's an
interesting unintended experiments that
we subject ourselves to well it's a
great example that you that you brought
up there because in that period they
would there was the the air traffic was
only down for a few weeks and that
wasn't really enough to kind of pull out
the signal that's from the contrails
what they do to the climate from to kind
of disentangle that from just the
weather but like this situation that we
have here is going to be longer and more
long-lasting and I think we will in fact
get an answer to that same question this
will help your models become more
accurate yes it's a pretty high price to
pay for a few improvements in a model
but well Gavin great to have you back on
Startalk you just up the street we want
to make sure you stay within arm's reach
of us because we'll surely find or exact
so I used to get with will find where
invent some excuse to get you back on
okay all right when we come back to you
star o'clock we're gonna have a chat
with climate scientist Katherine
on that next section
in the corona verse and this addition of
star talk it is any connection at all
between the coronavirus and climate
change
yeah and so for this segment we're
bringing in a new expert a new guest and
this is gonna be Katharine Hayhoe
Katharine did I pronounce your name
correctly you did heigh-ho so Katherine
you had director of the Texas Tech
Climate Center and and in that capacity
you also serve as professor at Texas
Tech in what department are you well I
have had a varied career my
undergraduate degree is in astrophysics
my Master's yes my masters in PhD is in
atmospheric science and I am currently
in the political science department at
Texas Tech because climate change is the
most political science there is don't
tell me that I don't want to hear that
snow yeah look at that for a minute Mia
was all excited you said astrophysics he
was like oh here's the story and you'll
appreciate this so I was planning to
continue to graduate school in
astrophysics I was studying galaxies
cluster around quasars I absolutely
loved it I was analyzing CCD images from
the candy France Hawaii telescope and I
took a class on climate science to
finish my undergraduate degree and it
completely floored me because I had no
idea that climate change was the very
same physics that I've been learning a
radiative transfer and nonlinear fluid
dynamics and even an orbital mechanics
it's the same physics and I had no idea
that climate change is a threat
multiplier but it was taking all of the
issues we already cope with today making
them worse and so in my naivete as a
student I thought oh well I'll just do
everything I can to help with climate
change now and it's so urgent it surely
will fix it and then I'll go back to
astrophysics stupid
dog how could you be so much yeah so yes
we didn't fix the car right didn't fix
the climate problem yeah and so so your
so you the need for you was more urgent
than ever in this world that's what it
felt like yeah yeah without it down so
what is it so there you is so you took
the off-ramp and never came back on well
I wanted to come back on I'm still
waiting to come back that's pretty wild
that's you know what it's kind of cool
that this is like your your trajectory
or your planned trajectory is that we're
gonna solve this problem and then you're
gonna go back to astrophysics it and so
that's beautiful the cool thing is that
the day that I see Katharine Hayhoe
on CBS this morning just talking about
astrophysics I know that we've actually
be climate crisis and you'll also know
that Neil is probably dead so I don't
get big-headed about that I just live
closer to CBS NBC and ABC then you do in
Lubbock Texas exactly that's why you're
gonna be on there talking astrophysics
which we need because it's the same
science people need to understand that
the physics is the physics no matter
whether we're here on earth on the other
side of the universe and it explains
both our planet and how it operates as
well as how the universe operates so
tell me now how why are we talking to
you about the Coronas virus we are
really concerned right now obviously
about the impact of this pandemic on our
world but the reason why we're concerned
is because it affects our health our
welfare in the economy of our families
our loved ones our communities our
cities our countries and that is exactly
what climate change affects too just
over a longer time scale so this is like
a microcosm
of what it's it's a it's a it's a
disaster real playing out in fast motion
right yeah that's that's exactly what it
is it is playing out in a matter of days
where as climate change plays out in
years to decades but in terms of where
we are with climate change we are as if
we're in the second week of March on the
corona virus pandemic in terms of how
far we've already progressed and how
great and how imminent the risk is that
we face today
so to tell me about ecosystems and the
spread of the corona virus or the
existence of the corona virus in the
first place or any virus especially
species jumping viruses how is that all
interconnected so corona virus came to
humans to a process called zoonosis that
means it jumped from animals to humans
that's a word that's a word yes
absolutely or it actually sounds like a
nude like kids program on Saturday Mary
no it sounds like it sounds like a dr.
Seuss yeah that's you know welcome to
zoo kids doesn't it it does it's like
I'm you're happy zoo keeper you know but
I Katherine I gotta give a talk and
whoever came up with that word later on
but go on continues yes so so it is not
a happy event is just the opposite it is
where a virus that already exists in an
animal population jumps over to humans
and we have no immunity to it and we are
incredibly vulnerable so the fact that
it jumped over to humans is primarily
due to the fact that animals like
penguins were being sold in wildlife
markets it's like an armadillo almost
it's like a kind of an arm a really
armored looking little animal like an
armadillo but nobody should be eating
what's it called again
jingling okay for a moment I thought you
were saying penguins and I was gonna say
Katherine I know you're a scientist but
I think you're mistaken I don't think
you should be eating penguins even
okay continue yes but but we know that
first of all as human expansion shrinks
wildlife areas and fragments ecosystems
humans are coming into more and more
contact with animal populations that
have nowhere to go
and then as climate changes changing
where different types of vegetation grow
where different animal species live
increasing the risk of droughts that
wipe out food supply that's also making
animals more desperate and more likely
to engage with humans in their search
for food which puts us additionally at
risk from getting more of these diseases
making that junk from animals over to
humans where we kept you you're you're
freaking me out of this morning what
you're saying is I don't want the words
in your mouth so you correct me if I'm
wrong that the coronavirus is just one
example of what will continue to happen
going forward as we displace ecosystems
yes coronavirus could be the new normal
we've already seen a few of these this
is not the first time we've seen SARS
we've seen the swine flu in fact we saw
the Spanish pandemic back over 100 years
ago which is the reason why my last name
is hey-ho so so so Katherine tell me
about what roles governments well
governments learn something from the
coronavirus that they can then apply to
staving off climate change come on I'm
supposed to be doing the comedy come on
man try to put me out of a job what is
happening all right let me just say one
would hope so and one would hope that
the basic lesson they would learn is an
ounce of prevention is worth a pound of
cure this is not forgive me for saying
this rocket science it's just
understanding that a stitch in time
saves nine preparing for in preventing
future risk
it's a lot safer and more affordable
than waiting for the tsunami to roll
over your head and then trying to
survive it can you talk about the fact
that food insecurity is a big deal right
now because a corona virus and food
insecurity with respect to climate
because that's when things get really
real when people can't eat that's when
the proverbial s hits the fan mm-hmm
well I'll tell you that going all the
way back to when I decided that I had to
do my best to study climate change
instead of astrophysics what stabbed me
in the heart what made me really change
my mind and what to do with my life was
when I found out that the poorest people
in the world were the ones who are most
affected by a changing climate and we
are seeing that play out here today let
me give you a couple of examples so
first of all I was talking to colleagues
who live around the world and they were
saying people who live in poor countries
the middle-class people are sitting in
their air-conditioned homes with the
groceries they ordered online and
Netflix and Internet and poor people
can't go out to get jobs to support
their families and they're even beat up
and arrested if they do go out because
of the quarantines but they can't even
feed their families here in the United
States we are seeing that
african-american populations are being
disproportionately affected by this
disease we don't know for sure but I
suspect it's what we're seeing around
the world people who already live in
areas with very poor air quality which
is primarily due to burning fossil fuels
which is what causes climate change
those people are much more vulnerable a
study they did on SARS like 15 years ago
showed that if you caught SARS and you
lived in an area with very dirty air you
were twice as likely to die from it as
if you lived in a place with clean air
and so we know that that is the case in
the u.s. today and then there's the
issue of like you just said food
shortages and food security the more
well-off an affluent we are the better
insulated we are at least for the first
few months from the impacts of pandemics
from climate change from disasters it is
always the poorest and the most
vulnerable who suffer first all right so
you're in a department of political
science
so you
these are people who who presumably care
what you say because you're coming to
them from an entire scientific
foundation of an understanding of the
past present and future of nature and
our intersection with it so what kind of
an audience do you get I would say that
many of the political scientists I've
spoken with are even more worried about
this than climate scientists if you can
imagine yes because they know that one
of the first things to go as disasters
build up in the world one of the first
things to go are democratic systems
mm-hmm that's ugly oh that's scary
yeah that is scary I mean it becomes
more totalitarian people are willing to
cede more control to a leader in a time
of disaster that sounds absolutely great
I couldn't resist it that was not a
political statement do not do not write
me do not tweet at me it was merely a
joke okay
on that note we will bring this segment
to a close when we come back to start
off more the corona virus and its other
similarities to climate change and start
our culture
we're back start up in the corona furs
keeping our distances not physical
distances but we are totally in each
others face electronically
ain't that right I've got with me some
extra expertise in the guys Katharine
Katharine Hayhoe welcome back to
Startalk in this segment and just to
remind people she's director of the
Texas Tech Climate Center very cool and
she has an ear she has the ear of
political scientists who cared emic
political scientists in particular who
care about things that could disrupt the
applecart of politics if I may call it
that so let me ask you Katherine could
you tell me about any similarities you
see about people's attitudes towards
climate change plus-or-minus
and attitudes towards this Cove in
nineteen coronavirus absolutely so for a
long time we've known here in the US and
sadly increasingly in other countries
around the world my home of Canada the
UK Australia and more that the number
one predictor of whether we agree with
over a hundred years of science that
tells us that digging up and burning
coal gas and oil is wrapping an extra
blanket around the planet that's causing
it to warm the number one predictor of
whether we agree with those facts is not
how smart we are it's not how much
science we know it's not how educated we
are it is simply where we fall on the
political spectrum and today we see that
the further to the right we are on the
political spectrum in the United States
the more likely we are to dismiss the
risks posed by the corona virus pandemic
as well so hmm why wait so it does one
cause the other or the other cause the
other I mean they're they're both
symptoms I think the underlying causes
fear it's fear that the world is
just changing too quickly that people
who have sort of been at the top of the
heat for a long time are feeling like
they're being shoved to the back of the
line and that anything that talks about
change whether it's immigration whether
it's you know government solutions
whether it's clean energy I mean we've
been using coal since the Middle Ages
what's wrong with it anything that's new
is seen as a threat to the established
all right so so when you say fear you
don't mean fear of the consequences of
climate change or the virus you mean
fear of a change in their
socio-political status absolutely mmm so
you will resist see so why don't if okay
let me just ask you if I don't want my
status to change why don't I just
declare I don't want to make these
changes I see the science I agree with
the science I don't want to change
policy based on it why don't they and
why don't they just do that that would
be the honest thing to do and some
people actually do you do that but a lot
of people are self defense mechanisms
kick in 99.9% of the climate denial I
see is actually solution aversion but
the solution aversion will arrive
cloaked in either a sciency or
religiously sounding smokescreen in
other words it's just a natural cycle
it's the Sun God is in control but when
you dig down anywhere from 30 seconds to
a minute on their own initiative people
will say well I don't want to fix this
problem because it means government
control I can't drive my truck I can't
do my job
China is gonna take over the world but
our psychology comes into play because
if I say it's a real problem and it will
hurt the poorest people in the world but
I don't want to fix it that makes me the
bad guy and none of us want to be the
bad guy
we want to be the good person and so we
throw up this this defense mechanism to
explain why we are good and smart in
rejecting this problem if it were not
good would at least be neutral so are
you are you trying to tell me that if I
don't give a damn about poor people that
I'm a bad person Catherine because I
gotta tell you the truth I don't I don't
give a damn about poor people I'm just
saying if all of my friends are rich
Catherine I'm just letting you know
right now all right so wait so let me
dig in just a little deeper so what
about those who who are conspiracy prone
mm-hmm and you get some of those in
every big scientific political issue and
even every science issue just whether we
landed on the moon whether we earth is
flat we're round and so have you seen
any similarities between the pandemic
and and climate change with regard to
just claims of conspiracy yes in fact
some of the very same organizations that
regularly spread conspiracy theories
about climate change have been spreading
conspiracy theories about the pandemic
as well oh my goodness that's all the
same so it's conspiracy central then
it's and when I met colleague Steve link
Lewandowski he's a cognitive
psychologist at the University of
Bristol in the UK that's my favorite
kind of psychologist by the way yeah yes
he's great so Steve has studied
conspiracy theories in general
everything from the Queen killed
Princess Diana to there's this
international cabal of scientists
opinion control and climate for 200
years
and he showed that they're all part and
parcel of the same mind set with my
whether seen as so one day rule the
world definitely an episode of Family
Guy where Stewie takes his little
weather machine and he actually succeeds
in doing just that so so where do we go
from here
what what what's your advice I mean
you've I'd like the fact that you are at
this nexus of the science and the
politics and the pop culture something
that we know if any real solution has to
be put into effect it's got to influence
politics it's got to influence people's
hearts and minds so you know I'm
reminded
when everyone was hauling whales out of
the ocean because they're really useful
the whale blubber is useful through for
light and fuel oil and God heads were
the days and then there people who
didn't want to kill these big beautiful
creatures and then we stopped killing
the big beautiful creatures is it
because of this movement no it's because
we found oil in the ground and didn't
need the whales and that your life was
not at risk pulling oil out of the
ground compared to whaling vessels so
that maybe you're not gonna convince
people's hearts and minds Katherine you
have to come up with an economic
solution that everybody can embrace and
then people will just do it so are we in
there I'm gonna be totally honest so
first of all I'm not an economist but I
listen to economists and nearly every
economist in the world and Tooting
including the two who won the Nobel
Prize a year and a half ago agree that
the most effective way to start cutting
carbon emissions is to restore the
massive imbalance between the cost of
fossil fuels and clean energy most
people think that clean energy is
massively subsidized and fossil fuels
aren't and it's exactly the opposite
direct subsidies on fossil fuels in the
u.s. are about double the subsidies and
renewables and if you include the
indirect subsidies from the air
pollution from two hundred thousand
deaths in the US alone every year from
the air pollution from fossil fuels if
you include the indirect the subsidies
to fossil fuels exceed the Pentagon's
budget so a price on carbon would
restore the balance so that we would see
that actually clean energy is much
cheaper and even with this imbalance
system wind is already cheaper up the
whole middle of the country for
electricity and solar is already cheaper
in the southwest then natural gas or
coal so why aren't you succeeding well
the interesting thing is that there's
actually a bipartisan climate solutions
caucus in Congress nice I never do that
have you have you testified to them
I know tell me about the co2 were not
putting the atmosphere now relative to
any long-term climate goals yes so under
the Paris agreement pretty much every
country in the world agree to try to
limit global warming to two degrees see
noting that we're already at 1 degree C
so 2 degrees Celsius or 1 and a half if
we could because there's no magic number
like if we end up at 1 and a half we'll
be totally fine and 1.6 we'll be totally
screwed it's like cigarettes the more
cigarettes you smoke the worse it is so
if we want to end up at one and a half
degrees then one way to get there is to
cut our carbon emissions pretty quickly
we'd need about a 40% cut by 2030 and we
need a hundred percent cut by about the
middle of the century and that sounds
like astronomical human human emissions
but here's the thing what just back up
for a second so that the target is one
and a half degrees Celsius over how much
time
stabilize it at one and a half degrees
Celsius by the end of the century oh so
what you're saying is whatever more we
warm the earth mm-hmm
don't warm it more than by one and a
half degrees right so we're already kind
of up to here do we kind of plateau or
do we just keep on going up got it got
it isn't it isn't it true that let's say
we were to make those targets right and
make them right when we're supposed to
that there is much like the economy
climate has a lag time so we're still
going to see increases in you know the
warming that's absolutely true and
that's why after mid-century we'd have
to start sucking this stuff back out of
the atmosphere Wow so it is I'm sorry so
we have to reduce you know and and then
we actually have to extract yes and that
extracting can be done in some very
low-tech ways planting trees is one way
to do it but there's also some really
cool high-tech ways they've couple of
really smart companies have figured out
how to suck
the atmosphere and they can turn it into
liquid fuel okay now you're just making
stuff up I just want to refocus this so
if we promise to asymptotically get to
one and a half degrees okay there's
still the matter of all the co2 that's
in the oceans dissolved right that'll
still keep coming out which is why you
were saying we have to keep extracting
it out of the air is that correct yes so
the ocean can get back and balance with
the atmosphere so it sounds like a big
number but here's the thing if you look
at how we've reduced our carbon
emissions due to the pandemic in just a
few weeks not on purpose
no and not sustainably we couldn't
sustain a reduction that's due to
shutting down the economy and throwing
people out of work I mean that is bad
but if we had achieved it through
increases in efficiency through clean
energy and through drawing down carbon
we would be a quarter of the way to
meeting our Paris agreement targets in
just a few weeks
Wow Wow I mean that's encouraging though
yeah yeah it shows that if the throat is
actually staring us in the eyeballs it
shows that we can do it but the problem
is this as you yourself just said Neil
it's a time frame issue climate change
unrolls in slow motion and I'm really
afraid as a scientist that by the time
we get to the point when disaster
staring every single human in the eye
it's gonna be too late to act all right
let me ask you a final question here
because running out of time what forgive
me for borrowing a medical term here
what's what advice do you give people to
inoculate themselves against bad science
oh I see what you did there when it
comes to not only climate change but
also the coronavirus well so inoculation
is really important because we live in a
world today where somebody thinks that
if they can Google something they know
more than experts and so inoculating
ourselves against fake news it's
something I do with my students I take
my students through things and I say if
something sounds too extreme or too good
to be true
it probably is if if something was said
by dr. so-and-so Google dr. so-and-so do
they actually have expertise in what
they're talking about or not take
everything with a grain of salt
depending on what media outlet you're
getting it from because we know that
certain ones skew more left other schema
right and then you have ones that are
extremely factual like Startalk of
course as well as well as like you know
the BBC and the CBC kind of national
news networks in Canada and and the UK
that have to just stick to the facts but
I think that really being aware that
just because something is on the
internet doesn't mean it's real just
because a politician said something
doesn't mean it's real I think that's
really key to learning or to starting
our journey towards and oscillating
ourselves can you tell me if there's a
way to fact-check
or google the source a lot of people say
or many people say is is there a way
that you can confirm that because a lot
of people say that this is a hoax oh yes
so I checked people to Snopes all the
time when in doubt go to snopes.com I'm
in the dark here guys what is Snopes
Dutch Chuck I'm seriously I don't
what is Snopes okay smoked cheques
anything that you might even be a little
suspicious of the authenticity of its
content or of its origin
all right that's why I don't know it
that's what I got you for so there's
there's an organization called climate
feedback and what they do is they've
gotten climate scientists together to
peer review news articles and they give
the news articles a rating of
truthfulness so any news article that
fights a politician or an organization
they actually have it peer reviewed on
climate feedback Wow what's what website
is that climate feedback orgy nice nice
okay
that's a new one for me I'm going there
tonight Katherine we got a we got to end
this give us give us
one last bit of wisdom that you'll that
you can share the Startalk universe I
think the pandemic has taught us all
that no matter who we are no matter what
country we live in no matter what
language we speak no matter where we
fall in a political spectrum when it all
comes down to it what really matters to
all of us is the health and the
well-being of our family our loved ones
our friends our community and more
that's exactly why we care about climate
change too and that's why I no matter
who we are no matter where we live no
matter what language we speak no matter
what car the political spectrum were on
we are already the perfect person to
care about climate change because we're
a human who lives on this earth that's a
mic drop
that's a mic drop much Katharine Hayhoe
love having you on here we'd want to get
you again any time this is great we will
definitely find a way to we'll invent an
excuse to bring you back on free thanks
and regards to your family stay safe
stay warm stay fed and keep trying to
change the world you - no thank you
all right Chuck always good having you I
was a pleasure now
all right this has been star talk in the
corona verse a special installment on
the corona virus versus climate change
you didn't think we could do that but we
did I've been your host Neil deGrasse
Tyson your personal astrophysicist as
always
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]